A veces esos momentos son alegres,
y a veces son desgarradores,
trágicos.
Pero en esos momentos decisivos, si podemos tomar la decisión correcta,
manifestamos literalmente un milagro
en nosotros y en otros.
Mi único hijo Tariq, un estudiante universitario
amable y generoso, un buen escritor y un buen fotógrafo,
aspiraba a trabajar para National Geographic,
comprometerse con una hermosa mujer,
trabajaba como repartidor de pizza los viernes y sábados.
Fue atraído a una dirección falsa
por una banda juvenil.
Y en una iniciación de pandilla
un chico de 14 años le disparó y lo mató.
La muerte repentina y sin sentido
de un ser humano, inocente y desarmado,
la abrumadora pena de una familia,
la completa confusión mientras tratas de absorber una realidad nueva y espantosa.
No hace falta decir que trajo un alto a mi vida.
Una de las cosas más difíciles que tuve que hacer
fue llamar a su madre, que vivía en otra ciudad.
¿Cómo le dices a una madre que nunca volverá a ver a su hijo de nuevo,
o a escucharlo reír,
o a darle un abrazo?
Soy practicante musulmán sufí.
Medito dos horas al día.
Y, a veces,
en el trauma profundo y la tragedia profunda,
hay una chispa de claridad.
Así que lo que saqué de mi meditación
es que había víctimas a ambos lados del arma.
Es fácil ver que mi hijo fue víctima de un chico de 14 años,
un poco más complicado es ver que fue víctima de la sociedad de EE.UU.
Y eso lleva a la pregunta, bueno, ¿quién es la sociedad de EE.UU.?
Bueno, somos tú y yo,
porque no creo que la sociedad sea solo casualidad.
Creo que todos somos responsables de la sociedad que hemos creado.
Y ver niños que matan a otros niños no es una señal de civilidad.
Así que nueve meses después de la muerte de Tariq,
creé la Fundación Tariq Khamisa
y nuestro mandato en la Fundación Tariq Khamisa
es evitar que haya niños que maten a otros niños
y romper el ciclo de violencia juvenil.
Y esencialmente tenemos tres objetivos.
El primero y principal es salvar la vida de los niños.
Es importante hacerlo. Perdemos muchos niños todos los días.
Nuestro segundo objetivo
es alentar las elecciones correctas para que los niños no caigan por las grietas
y elijan vidas de pandillas, crimen, drogas, alcohol y armas.
Y el tercer objetivo es enseñar los principios de la no violencia,
la empatía, la compasión
y el perdón.
Y empecé con una premisa muy simple
de que la violencia es un comportamiento aprendido.
Ningún niño nace violento.
Si aceptamos eso como una verdad,
la no violencia también puede ser un comportamiento aprendido,
pero hay que enseñarla,
porque los niños no van a aprender eso
por ósmosis.
Poco después, me acerqué a mi hermano aquí presente,
con la actitud de que ambos habíamos perdido a un hijo.
Mi hijo murió.
Él perdió a su nieto en el sistema penitenciario adulto.
Y le pedí que me acompañara.
Como pueden ver, 22 años después, seguimos aquí juntos,
porque no puedo traer a Tariq de entre los muertos,
tú no puedes sacar a Tony de prisión,
pero lo único que podemos hacer
es asegurarnos de que ningún otro joven de nuestra comunidad
termine muerto o en prisión.
Por la gracia de Dios,
la Fundación Tariq Khamisa ha sido exitosa.
Tenemos un modelo de escuela seguro
que tiene cuatro programas diferentes.
El primero es una conferencia con Ples y conmigo.
Somos presentados,
el nieto de este hombre mató al hijo de este hombre,
y aquí están juntos.
Tenemos un plan de estudios para el aula.
Tenemos un programa de tutoría después de clase y creamos un club de paz.
Y estoy feliz de compartir con Uds.
que además de enseñar estos principios de no violencia
podemos detener la deserción escolar y las expulsiones en un 70 %,
algo enorme.
(Aplausos)
Algo enorme.
Cinco años después de la muerte de Tariq
y para culminar mi viaje de perdón,
fui a ver al muchacho que mató a mi hijo.
Tenía 19 años.
Y recuerdo esa reunión porque estábamos...
él tiene 37, todavía está en prisión...
pero en esa primera reunión, cruzamos miradas.
Lo miro a los ojos, él mira los míos,
y lo miré a los ojos tratando de encontrar a un asesino y no fue así.
Pude atravesar sus ojos
y tocar su humanidad y encontrar
que la chispa en él no era diferente de la chispa en mí
o cualquier otra persona aquí presente.
No me esperaba eso. Él estaba arrepentido.
Hablaba bien. Era educado.
Me di cuenta de que mi mano de perdón lo había cambiado.
Y con eso, por favor reciban a mi hermano, Ples.
(Aplausos)
Ples Felix: Tony es el único hijo de mi única hija.
Tony nació de mi hija,
que tenía 15 cuando dio a luz a Tony.
La maternidad es el trabajo más duro del planeta.
No hay trabajo más duro en el planeta que criar a otro ser humano
y asegurarse de que está seguro, protegido
y bien posicionado para ser exitoso en la vida.
Tony experimentó mucha violencia en su vida de pequeño.
Vio a uno de sus primos favoritos
ser asesinado en un tiroteo de armas automáticas
y participó de pandillas en Los Ángeles.
Estaba muy traumatizado.
Tony vino a vivir conmigo.
Quería asegurarme de que tuviera todo lo que un niño necesitaba
para prosperar.
Pero esa noche en particular,
después de años conmigo
y luchar fuertemente por tratar de tener éxito
y de alcanzar mis expectativas de ser una persona exitosa,
ese día en particular, Tony escapó de casa esa noche,
salió a estar con personas que él creía eran sus amigos,
le dieron drogas y alcohol
y él las tomó
porque pensó que lo harían sentir relajado.
Pero eso solo aumentó su ansiedad
y tuvo una idea...
mucho más letal de su parte.
Fue invitado a un robo,
se le dio una pistola 9 mm.
Y en presencia de un muchacho de 18 años que lo comandaba
y dos chicos de 14 años que él pensaba que eran sus amigos,
le disparó y mató a Tariq Khamisa,
el hijo de este hombre.
No hay palabras, no hay palabras
que puedan expresar la pérdida de un hijo.
Al comprender que mi nieto era responsable
del asesinato de este ser humano,
fui al oratorio, como me enseñaron mis padres,
y comencé a rezar y meditar.
Lo único que el Sr. Khamisa y yo tenemos en común,
y no lo sabíamos, además de ser maravillosos seres humanos,
es que ambos meditamos.
(Risas)
Fue de mucha ayuda para mí
porque me dio la oportunidad de buscar guía y claridad
para ser apoyo para este hombre y su familia ante esta pérdida.
Y con seguridad, mis plegarias fueron escuchadas,
porque fui invitado a una reunión en la casa de este hombre,
conocí a su madre, su padre,
su esposa, su hermano, conocí a su familia
y pude estar en presencia de personas espirituales guiadas por este hombre
quien en el camino hacia el perdón,
hizo lugar, creó una oportunidad para mí
para ser de valor y compartir con él y compartir con los niños
la importancia de entender la necesidad de estar con un adulto responsable,
centrarse en el enojo de manera saludable,
aprender a meditar.
Los programas que tenemos en la Fundación Tariq Khamisa
brindan instrumentos a los niños
para que las lleven el resto de sus vidas.
Es importante que los niños comprendan que hay adultos interesados y amorosos
que se preocupan por ellos y los apoyan,
pero también es importante que nuestros niños aprendan a meditar.
aprendan a ser pacíficos,
a estar centrados
y aprendan a interactuar con otros niños
de una forma amable, empática
y maravillosamente amorosa.
Necesitamos aprender más amor en nuestra sociedad
y es por eso que estamos aquí para compartir el amor con los niños,
porque nuestros niños nos marcarán el camino,
porque todos dependeremos de nuestros niños.
Al envejecer y retiramos, ellos se encargarán del mundo por nosotros
así que mientras más amor les enseñemos, ellos nos lo devolverán.
Bendiciones. Gracias.
(Aplausos)
AK: Yo nací en Kenia, fui educado en Inglaterra,
y mi hermano de aquí es bautista.
Practico como musulmán sufí.
Él es afroestadounidense,
pero yo siempre le digo, que yo soy el afroestadounidense del grupo.
Yo nací en África. Tú no.
(Risas)
Y estoy naturalizado como ciudadano.
Soy un ciudadano de primera generación.
Y sentí, como ciudadano de EE.UU.,
que debía asumir responsabilidad
por el asesinato de mi hijo.
¿Por qué? Porque le disparó un niño de EE.UU.
Podrían adoptar la postura, de que mató a mi único hijo,
debería ser colgado del poste más alto.
¿Cómo mejora eso a la sociedad?
Y sé que probablemente se están preguntando qué le pasó a ese chico.
Todavía está en prisión. Acaba de cumplir 37 el 22 de septiembre,
pero tengo buenas noticias.
Hemos estado tratando de sacarlo durante 12 años.
Finalmente, se nos unirá dentro de un año.
(Aplausos)
Y estoy muy entusiasmado de que se nos una,
porque sé que lo hemos salvado,
pero el salvará a decenas de miles de estudiantes
cuando comparta su testimonio
en las escuelas donde nos presentamos a diario.
Cuando le diga a los niños, "Cuando tenía 11 me uní a una pandilla.
Cuando tenía 14, maté al hijo del Sr. Khamisa.
He pasado los últimos tantísimos años en prisión.
Estoy aquí para decirles: no vale la pena",
¿Uds. creen que los niños escucharán esa voz?
Sí, porque su entonación
será la de una persona que disparó el gatillo.
Y yo sé que quiere retroceder el tiempo.
Por supuesto, eso no es posible.
Desearía que lo fuera. Tendría a mi hijo de vuelta.
Mi hermano tendría a su nieto de vuelta.
Así que creo que eso demuestra el poder del perdón.
Entonces ¿cuál es la gran lección para llevarse de aquí?
Quería terminar nuestra sesión con esta frase,
que es la base de mi cuarto libro
y, dicho sea de paso,
el prefacio de ese libro fue escrito por Tony.
Dice así: "La buena voluntad sostenida crea amistad".
No haces amigos bombardeándolos, ¿verdad?
Haces amigos esparciendo buena voluntad.
Eso debería ser obvio.
Así que "la buena voluntad crea amistad,
la amistad sostenida crea confianza,
la confianza sostenida crea empatía,
la empatía sostenida crea compasión
y la compasión sostenida crea paz".
Le llamo a esto mi fórmula de la paz.
Empieza con buena voluntad, amistad, confianza, empatía, compasión y paz.
Pero la gente me pregunta ¿cómo extiendo la buena voluntad
a la persona que asesinó a mi hijo?
Yo les digo, lo haces a través del perdón.
Como es evidente funcionó para mí.
Funcionó para mi familia.
Lo que es un milagro es que si funcionó para Tony,
funcionó para su familia,
puede funcionar para ti y tu familia,
para Israel y Palestina, Corea del Norte y del Sur,
para Irak, Afganistán, Irán y Siria.
Puede funcionar para Estados Unidos de América.
Así que déjenme concluir con esto, mis hermanas,
y un par de hermanos...
(Risas)
La paz es posible.
¿Cómo lo sé?
Porque estoy en paz.
Muchas gracias. Namasté.
(Aplausos)